now when you start looking at these
arguments and I invite you to reconsider
them
they're not actually very good arguments
there's holes in them that you can play
Plato wants you to find those holes
that's part of why he set up the
dialogue of what he did at first they
sound quite good
and and agathon is going to bring this
to a close by going into this long
speech this paragraph right about all
the things that love does and it is like
the finest oratory that you can you can
put on tap and sort of like listening to
um you know somebody like Martin Luther
King who was a great warrior himself
just get up and
everything follows from everything else
you know
every single word is perfectly chosen
but you have to ask yourself is this all
the sort of Glitz
or does it mean anything that's